the impeachment discussions about Donald
Trump are getting both very concrete and
much less I guess abstract by by
definition the chairman of the House
Judiciary is congresswoman Jerry Nadler
Nadler is now saying that robert molars
report contains quote very substantial
evidence that donald trump is quote
guilty of high crimes and misdemeanors
now you may know that there's a
particular relevance to that term high
crimes and misdemeanors are impeachable
offenses and this is sort of setting the
table for robert molars testimony later
this week on Wednesday where Nadler says
Moeller must be allowed to spell this
out in detail in front of the committee
if there were to be impeachment hearings
it would be Nadler House Judiciary
Committee which would lead them and
there is not agreement among the
Democratic Party about whether they
should pursue impeachment at this point
there are more than 80 Democrats who
called for starting the impeachment
inquiry immediately there are some
prominent Democrats like Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi and Nadler himself
who have been resistant to it so the
breaking news is not Nadler thinks
there's evidence okay I want to cut
right to sort of like the core of what's
important here it's time for the
impeachment discussion to become really
specific and narrow okay because it's
not good it's not healthy it's not
productive that every time some little
thing happens oh now might be the time
for impeachment but it might not and
Pelosi says no and who knows who says
yes I've been saying for months now that
there should be an impeachment inquiry
that starts in the house and that should
start immediately or as soon as possible
that's been my position get the contents
of the Moller report out in public make
everything in the report known to as
many people as possible but Democrats
need to make a decision about this and
they need to make that decision very
soon robert muller testifies wednesday
if the content of the report justifies
an impeachment inquiry which i believe
it does and remember the inquiry is just
step one in the entire process then that
inquiry should start immediate
after Robert molars testimony I happen
to believe having read the report that
the contents do justify an impeachment
inquiry if it's time to do it then let's
do it
if the idea and this is a respectable
position some have the idea that it
would be more damaging to Donald Trump
to start the impeachment inquiry in say
six months because the 2020 election
will be more ramped up at that point in
time there would be more disruption of
trumps campaign to be done at that time
when right now it's really just the
Democratic primary that's getting
attention that's that's fine let's come
to that agreement and let's shut our
mouths about it until that point the
constant back and forth the Democrats
fighting with each other about
impeachment inquiry versus not it will
not help remove Trump in 2020 the most
effective path forward would be let
Moeller speak on wednesday publicize
what he says and allow the truth of that
testimony to foment deserved outrage in
the United States we're going to learn
much more very soon about the Jeffrey
Epstein case and it is quite possible
that Donald Trump will be implicated in
some of those documents in some way
shape or form maybe not for the alleged
child rape that Donald Trump was accused
of but possibly let's get that
information out into the open and
allowed that to grow the outrage in the
country this could easily build for the
next five to seven months and then it
could be the perfect time to start the
impeachment inquiry when it would be
most damaging to Donald Trump now some
of you will hear me talking about this
and you'll be outraged concern trolling
David are you suggesting that Dems play
politics with the timing of something as
serious as impeachment yeah I am that's
what I'm doing we need to win okay the
right plays politics with the lives of
undocumented immigrants seeking asylum
the right plays politics with the lives
of civilians in Iran as Donald Trump
authorizes and then cancels a strike on
Iran they play politics with debt and
deficit in taxes and health care I'm
saying it's okay to play politics with
the timing of the impeachment inquiry
plus or minus a few months yes
that's what I'm saying it's time to stop
losing if calculating the timing of an
impeachment inquiry in order to most
damage Trump is what we have to do it is
nothing compared to what they've done
but Democrats need to decide what the
plan is like now because the worst
possible thing they can do is just
continue public infighting about it for
the next six months or 12 months or all
the way to the 2020 election that's how
Trump wins I don't want him to win so
it's time to really think about it do we
want to do it now do we want to do it in
six months or not at all and if that's
the case we focus on the 2020 election
but the infightings got to stop and the
back-and-forth has to end today let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show follow both of us there
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinkie's is
a great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is calm slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa que mas